the nfl is now down of course to its
final four
this weekend ron futrell taking a look
at uh the sports books and how they're
thinking about these two very good
matchups
okay so we got two championship games
going on this weekend first one's going
to be the bucks against the packers
and then of course the bills against the
chiefs the chiefs got the news they were
looking for
in that patrick mahomes a quarterback
who suffered a concussion last weekend
is ready to play in the sports books
have been on edge waiting for this news
like on a situation like this so we
won't take as big as many large wagers
as we do
early until we find out what the
quarterback situation is because
uh situations like this we seem to find
out about five minutes
after the the sharp people find out so
and so doesn't take us long to figure
out whether or not he's going to play or
not
interesting thing about the other game
now tampa bay against green bay
and the sports books want green bay to
win because there are a ton
of bets out there futures bets on the
tampa bay buccaneers right now to win
the super bowl millions of dollars worth
of bets
on the bucks i'm talking about probably
two three million dollars at least
uh maybe three four million dollars for
the state so you know nobody
none of the bookmakers behind the
counter are buccaneer fans this weekend
so at last check the green bay packers
are three and a half point favorites
over the tampa bay buccaneers
and the kansas city chiefs three-point
favorites over the buffalo bills
i'm ron fuchar reporting eight sports
now all right ron yeah mahomes plane is
huge